we're not yeah can you take minnekopa
among the plates it's just downstairs
this is Nigel and Derek a pair of lab
rats who decided to drink soda from the
fridge without leaving their chair this
is one of those cases where being lazy
actually leads you to do a heck of a lot
more work after starting with a
three-foot straw in Derek's Australian
condo the pair built up to a daring 20
foot mega straw
[Music]
yeah you can see it's a strong start
[Music]
so is nodular total sucker or is science
lending a helping hand people assume
that they're sucking the liquid or at
which a more accurate description is
that what they're doing is is creating a
vacuum they're removing the air from the
straw so you have a scenario here where
at one end of the straw you have low
pressure created by the expansion of
their lungs and at the other end in the
ground you have an atmospheric pressure
exerting a force on the liquid so
there's a lot of force it's naturally
gonna push all the liquid up and that's
how it comes them out well done Nigel
and Derrick
[Music]